this is what the Texas texas.gov sent me
to it says so when can you use deadly
force in Texas to protect property Texas
law allows you to use deadly force to
protect property if you would be
justified using force and you reasonably
believe it is imminently necessary
immediately necessary to prevent the
imminent Commission of specific
enumerated property crimes these are
arson burglary robbery aggravated
robbery theft during the night time or
criminal mischief during the night time
so it does say specifically if if you
see someone trying to steal property
from you
and then you shoot them that's a serious
felony if they turn towards you that
changes everything
so it's and I also kind of think like
nighttime Mischief in general is my
favorite thing to be in criminal statute
Mischief during the night time just like
nighttime Mischief I just think that but
but you probably all got involved in
nighttime Mischief when we were kids so
that's also terrifying because I grew up
in Texas but I think I think the reason
for these laws in places like Texas is
they typically want you to be able to
defend yourself from crime but they
don't want people to randomly shoot
people so exactly you know I was talking
to someone in West Virginia and I said
what if someone enters my property in
West Virginia can I defend it and I
think I was talking to a cop actually he
said if someone just is walking on your
land you can't just shoot them because
people accidentally walk on land a lot
however legally
you can defend your property from
someone who is committing a crime and
enters the property so you know
basically you you need to be able to
justify why you thought they were
committing crime or something like that
despite the fact that it's kind of more
vague than you can articulate the
reasons and those reasons would be
justifiable and it's and that's very
subjective the way you articulate it
they always say this uh in government
service it's like it's not what you did
it's how you write it up yeah okay and
then the military is very familiar with
this too it's the way you get Awards and
certain commendations if you justify it
if it's articulated properly then you
can have a lot of things happen in your
favor and vice versa too somebody could
articulate that you were doing something
that was totally justifiable they can
articulate it in a bad way and here
here's the important thing too it says
the jury must decide whether you had a
reasonable belief that deadly force was
immediately necessary to prevent a
perpetrator from fleeing yeah I wonder
uh says immediately after committing a
burglary robbery aggravated robbery or
theft during the nighttime
to stop them from fleeing right that's
kind of intense so so that's Texas for
you you have to give a reasonable belief
that deadly force is necessary what if
the only weapon available to you is a
nine millimeter
then easy to upgrade your Arsenal well
no this might actually clear you yeah if
that's all you have on you and what
because the only use of force you have
is considered deadly and you have no
other Alternatives or options is that
considered reasonable
yeah I mean that's that's the fun and
obviously it goes to a jury too the
other piece of this is do people run
around with uh restraints do you keep
Flex cuffs with you are you keeping
shoestring restraints because that's
actually the tool that should have
happened in the New York Subway system
right because the guy did something if
you could immediately incapacitate him
and a blood choke would have been
appropriate he's out for a few seconds
you zip tie up his hands real quick and
there aren't a kid and you can carry
those things around with you tourniquets
might be a little bit more difficult to
secure properly yeah but it's better
than nothing I'm just saying people
don't run around with duct tape they
don't run around with flex cuffs they
don't run around with what they call
like shoestring uh handcuffs which I
used to keep in my pockets all the time
because they're really effective but if
you don't have that thing and most
people don't then you're stuck holding
this guy until the next stop you're on
the F line until you get to the platform
I guess and that's the scary thing for
these people so you know tying it back
in there the reasonable standard is is
like what are they going to do let them
get up and be pissed I don't know if
you've ever if you've ever let somebody
up after they've had that sort of
experience they don't generally go like
yeah I'm de-escalating yeah once you
grab them that's it you're you're locked
in until the police comes like that that
guy didn't have a chance like an
opportunity or the option like if they
let him go he's all he was already
having an episode you're not going to
let the guy he's not going to be like
nah it's cool man I'm gonna chill now no
he'd have flipped out there's no
question about it yeah and it's you
don't risk it even if even even if maybe
he wouldn't have you don't risk it
because he gets up and next thing you
know he's on someone else you know yeah
so we've talked about this before I even
mentioned it earlier on the show but
just the propensity of left Wingers to
project often what they will accuse
conservatives of who act in the defense
of themselves or others as having a
misinformed view of violence based on
watching action movies oh you only want
guns because you think you're some kind
of Action Hero oh you're only trying to
save the Damsel in Distress because you
saw it in the film in reality their
understanding of how using Force works
is entirely Hollywood based right like
they really think you can have a fight
some with somebody the way they do in a
Marvel movie or in a choreographed fight
scene where you're like just standing
apart like boxing each other and then
you get the bad guy down and then you
say stay there fella and he stays down
without getting back up I mean in real
life self-defense situations are
incredibly messy they're incredibly
messy but because people are used to
seeing these choreographed fight scenes
in Hollywood movies where the good guy
subdues the bad guy without hurting him
they think that your average person
should be able to do that Sheamus I've
seen the movies where like you know
Black Widow trips a guy and he falls on
it just doesn't get back up exactly that
there's no way they just made that up
that's not the Magic The Magic hit where
they like hit you with either like their
fist or they hit you with the gun like
they piss to whip you and then you're
out however long you need to to the
scene ends that's my other favorite
thing yeah those are almost always
either lethal if you were to actually
hit that one hit or that person's gonna
get up and they are going to be resuming
their fighting posture because oh now in
a very dangerous spot I love this like
how many movies have the Trope where
someone gets hit in the forehead with a
gun and then they wake up tied up in a
chair yes as if getting knocked out is a
thing yep so uh for people who don't
know if you that's called being put in a
coma you are comatose if someone can use
blunt force to incapacitate you to the
point where you're not conscious you've
been put in a coma and my understanding
is that if it's longer than even like 30
seconds or so it's it is expected you
have very serious brain damage from that
so when the hero then wakes up like in I
think it's like Casino Royale or
whatever all of them it's all it's
always a rifle butt stroke right to the
foreign
no what happens is they think they took
out everyone in the room and they're
like and then the guy was like oh
snapshot dad like yells something in
German and hits him with the butt one
guy in the corner yeah exactly I beg
people that that think that kind of
stuff just go to a Jiu Jitsu gym for one
evening like just go and try and roll
with someone that that just roll with
the white belts like you know I mean I'm
a white belt I don't know anything at
all but if you've never rolled Jiu Jitsu
I could probably wrap you up you know
and and you know it's like I heard it's
hard Mark Zuckerberg won uh you know
kind of somewhere right looks like he's
a bad man now he may be an he may look
kind of nerdy but that that man is going
to do he has no reason not to exactly
yeah apparently he was in a match and
the ref said that he tapped out and he
didn't he got really angry or he's like
I didn't tell you nuts and then you need
to beat the ref
and then he bought the gym yeah he
bought the gym and fired the rap snapped
his finger and then all the refs Dirty
Secrets just publicly appeared on
everyone's videos yeah they just fell
out of all the Facebook you know secret
messages he was sending it's dirty it is
true though 100 like somebody who has
some training versus someone who has no
training it's not even fair someone who
is a professional versus someone who has
a lot of training even not even fair so
you look at these things and uh it's
it's just it's a total lack of an
understanding of the physical reality of
the world we live in and some of that
like you say propagated by Hollywood is
also that women might be able to do that
yes because that is not happening on
that Subway that man in a state of
mental duress whatever it was that he
walked in there the Jordan Neely
character when he walks in and decides
that he's going to lose it you've seen
that video of the guy and I who posted
it maybe it was Ian miles chunk too but
uh guy walks in grabs a handful of hair
and he's dressed like a woman yeah and
pulls it pulls her down to the ground
she can't go and no one stands up you
know what makes me the most frustrated
about that entire thing like it makes me
Furious is that the guy who's filming it
is like a pretty built male looking
masculine dude and he's holding his
phone doing the bystander thing he'll go
to jail
he'll go to jail Woody yes yeah look
what's happening with Daniel with that
with this guy Penny you know what I'd
rather go to jail I'm sorry I agree like
my Honor's not worth that it's it's not
worth it that I walk and go I let a
woman get dragged off and terrorized and
then she's going to think that every
single day of her life and yeah but she
voted for it
that bothers me just as a Christian
person I can't hold people accountable I
can't say on YouTube the answer that I
feel good about so listen listen if the
overwhelming majority of people in
places like Chicago La New York keep
voting for the same people over and over
again I actually think it is
it is a fascist of you to to imply that
your will be done and that their
Democratic vote be ignored so here's the
question so if they want to have another
did they have another option is the
other question because I've had this I I
tend to feel the same way you do on an
emotional level and I had someone
challenge me intellectually and this is
what they said they said was there a
viable alternative was there even an
alternative on the ballot in let's say
Chicago because no Republican ran not
that I think the Republican party is the
solution to anything at all uh based on
my personal experience so far but you
look at it and you go was there a was
there anyone else that could have voted
for and in Chicago whose fault is it
Paul vallis he was the right way he was
he was a moderate Democrat tough on
crime okay and they elected the far left
critical race Theory a socialist guy
what percentage did uh what is the name
Paul Valles what did he I think it was
fairly close I I think it was only a few
points for for um was it Brandon
Johnson's name I'm not completely sure
100 with you because Chicago politics
are basically not relevant Democrats
have run the city for 100 years not
going anywhere but the end of the day do
you hold the people that voted for the
other again is it their fault too
because that's the tough part I don't
know I just you do yeah I do okay like
tell me more after a hundred years of
the same thing it's like you're holding
your hand on the electric stove going
like man this shirt does suck but I'll
just keep staying here I just love the
smell of burnt flesh just I'll just stay
right here I left I got out of Chicago
yeah I'd been shot at before uh I'm me
and my brother are driving down uh we're
driving off of uh 290 and Independence
and for no reason a guy just points a
gun at our car and Fires at us that's
Chicago and So eventually I'm just like
you know like I kind of don't want to be
here it it feels like a nowhere town I
would tell my friends it's the suburb of
the country it's a big city but it's
culturally stagnant it's extremely
violent and nothing is changing about it
so I'm done I'm leaving I can get behind
that yeah like I say I just want the
question asked is there any way that
these people could not be culpable and
if the answer is no then the answer is
culpable is a strong word I would put it
this way I get messages from people and
they're like Tim I really need your help
you know we need to raise money for this
guy who's been being unjustly targeted
or whatever and I'm like where did it
happen oh it happened in Chicago
pass are you kidding dude come on man
like two years ago I said I know it's
hard but you got to leave these cities
and the way I describe it is people will
tell me it's really hard to do you want
to do you want me to tell you about how
I got out of Chicago I sold all my stuff
I had 400 bucks in cash I found a ride
share on Craigslist and said I will draw
he had two cars I said I'll drive one of
them behind you to San Diego that was it
and then look I'm I was like 22 or 23 at
the time whatever it's still a move and
a lot of people won't do it not like I
knew that La you know was how bad it was
going to be or whatever and uh
moderately bad but there's enough of La
is big enough to where I got by just
fine and actually found more success but
I'm like I'm not gonna stay here this
place sucks there's so many problems it
was so corrupt the cops were corrupt the
government was corrupt the crime was
rampant so I literally I was actually
intending on riding a moped I'm like I
will just be honest and I and again
people say like I have families I can't
do it so let me put it this way you are
sitting in a house and the garage is on
fire
is attached to rush
we see it happening oh your neighbor was
in the garage and he's screaming right
now and you're like yeah but I'm in the
living room and if and if and if I have
to go outside it's cold and I have kids
my kids can't be cold and it's like dude
your house is on fire if you stay inside
of it
you will lose your life it will get bad
if you leave your house now you will
survive and it will be very difficult so
the response I get for most people is
you don't know how hard it is and I'm
like Perhaps Perhaps Perhaps but doesn't
change the fact statement that staying
in place like Chicago New York Oregon
Portland for instance like come on it's
a no-go yeah it looks like it's crazy
how bad it is that and it's it may be
the hardest thing you've ever done but I
just there's not a whole lot I can say
to the fifth sixth person who's like
you know oh no this guy broke into my
house and I need to raise money my mom
was hurt and I'm just like
come on man no well here's the thing you
say it's hard and it is hard but I'm 41.
I got three kids I sold my house because
it was the right thing to do I left a
state that we were comfortable in we had
a palace we were on like two acres it
was awesome I had Mountain views that
like most people would stab for and we
we left because you can do it and we
moved into two bedrooms that were my
folks place that I didn't own which is
super embarrassing at 41 years old
nobody wants to go do that but at the
end of the day can you go do this yes is
it difficult sure but you still got to
do the right thing I agree with you they
should be moving I don't think there's
any saving a lot of these places I've
been to West Baltimore I see what it
gets to eventually West Baltimore looks
like there was a zombie invasion and we
lost and it's still going and it's still
there there's people that live there
it's crazy they're sections of Chicago
very much the same and it's and it's and
it's
it's kind of sad there's tremendous
opportunity in these they're massive
buildings on the south side of Chicago
completely abandoned yep and I'm just
thinking to myself can you just there's
tons of young people who want to do
things but there are these barriers as
bureaucracy but aside from that
you're talking about cities like Los
Angeles that had a Democrat super
majority and still couldn't solve the
homeless problem because they don't want
to solve the homeless problem because
they don't want to deal with any of the
issues they just want to give you
mindless self-indulgence and then
they'll take it and then crime runs
rampant and then they blame
conservatives they blame everyone else
well you look they always build they
always build like uh infrastructure
behind it they always build bureaucratic
systems that pay more of their buddies
to have a job but none of the jobs go to
like getting homeless people they get
more homeless people so putting money
into the problem makes more problem it's
it's this classic do you ever see the
demotivators you know no uh the
demotivism there was a whole thing in
the 90s of like motivational posters and
they'd have like a picture like hang in
there you can do it or whatever yeah so
I used to have one on my screen which
I'm sure was a fantastic for on a
government screen and it used to have a
picture of the US Capitol building and
it said government
um if you if you don't if you what do
they say it says uh if you don't like
our problems you should see our
Solutions
which is a which is a winner and it's
100 accurate but like that's kind of the
attitude like government creates these
things there's another one that was
about consultants and said Consultants
something to the effect of if you're not
going to be part of the solution there's
a ton of money in continuing the problem
and that is Los Angeles like that's the
homeless situation in Los Angeles they
are continuing the problem for profit
you can always move to Florida you could
well I just want to so that cities there
make a note or make a comment uh on the
the question of like bureaucracies
especially in the Chicago area so I was
also born and raised in Cook County and
I have a number of horror stories just
from people working within the various
government systems there someone I knew
insisted that when they first started a
job working for Cook County I won't say
what they did
they were working very hard
and they were getting ahead uh on their
well because it's also anecdotal right
but according to them they were getting
ahead on their work and during their
first week there and their co-workers
basically surrounded them and said we
don't do that much in a week that sounds
correct yeah we we don't we're just
letting you know like no that is a
classic government experience yeah at
all levels of government yeah what
happens if you like just say cool I'm
still gonna do it and then just make
everyone look really disciplinary action
yeah
throw you under the bus they've got
something something will come up look
you did your TPS report wasn't filed
correctly so look the other thing about
doing it I thought the government wasn't
garbage if you do a lot of work right
you now have more opportunities for them
to find procedural errors in your work
and so instead of people doing their job
they will spend every single minute of
their time to crush you because you are
upstanding the status quo just abolish
the whole thing and so bad get rid of
the whole damn thing it's it's the worst
solution to anything except when it's
the only one I think what's gonna happen
is
we're gonna hear more and more of these
stories someone's going to be like oh my
house was set on fire during the riots
what do I do it's like well should have
sold it a year ago that's right should
have sold it two years ago it's I don't
know because when it you know two three
years ago the Summer of Love three years
ago isn't that crazy and it's like well
what am I going to do there's these
riots going on it's like I get it this
sucks it's hard now it's been three
years if you have not taken the first
step towards getting away from these
cities in three years I don't know what
you expect anyone else to do for you no
matter how hard you think it is there
comes a point where it's just like
everybody left dude people went to Texas
down to Florida they went to the middle
of nowhere some people of West Virginia
and now you're gonna look around as as
antifa runs rampant and sets fire to
your institutions and shuts down your
infrastructure and then you're gonna bet
can someone please help me and there's
not gonna be anybody there yeah I I just
I don't think it's wise to bet on there
will be no more riots in these neighbors
we're one outrage away from whatever the
next trigger is right because it's not
about the it's not about the underlying
incident it's about the activity of
upsetting the the Apple car that some of
these people are just professional you
know pretty Wells I there's part of me
that thinks that there might not be
riots and before the election because
riots before the election make the
existing Administration look bad now I'm
not saying that it can't happen or
whatever I'm not making a prediction but
there's part of me that thinks it
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense for
the left to Riot and upset people the
your average noise
also like Riders are not political
strategists right no but their idea will
try to spin it any which way and I think
you're right that certain conditions can
be created for a right to flourish like
political leaders not cracking down on
them as they spring up so I hear what
you're saying there but it's possible
things just pop off they can't do
anything about it and they try to spin
it to sound like these riots are fiery
but mostly peaceful protests or whatever
label they want to throw on it see I'm
of the opinion that the right that the
riots were not organic I'm of the
opinion that they were they were people
were communicating with each other
letting other people that other leftist
there was antifa that were you know the
rioters and stuff the antifa network the
people that are in antifa they know each
other they communicate and so
and they're in in touch with like other
activists that are not rioters that are
people that'll you know they're in touch
with teachers at schools in in colleges
and stuff people that are fairly
intelligent people that can strategize
so I do think that and again I'm not
saying that I'm not making a prediction
but I do think that I wouldn't be
surprised if we don't see any kind of
significant rioting regardless of what
happens in the in the country just
because it will make it more difficult
for the left to win a for the Democrat
to win I just want to make one more
Point that's an interesting point that
could that could be accurate you could
be right about that but even so the
framing you have is
until it's convenient for there to be
more of course and so you don't want to
live in that neighborhood either way 100
100 yes I don't want to I don't I don't
want to cut down anyone's idea about
getting out of the terms of right get
out of the Cities if you can thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time